[Music]
episode two of the second season of the
disney plus hit the mandalorian was as
egg-centric as anything in the star wars
universe and that includes plenty of
tasty hidden easter eggs for fans to
spot
here are a few you may not have caught
after returning from the successful
crate dragon hunt
the mandalorian returns to mos eisley
and chapter 10 the passenger
to meet with pelemato he reports back
and lets her know that the supposed
mandalorian frequenting mos
pelgo was just a man in mandalorian
armor but she reassures him that she can
put him in contact with someone who can
lead him to his people
first she introduces him to dr mandible
a giant bug-like creature whose brief
screen time carries with it a couple of
meanings
mandible appears to be a member of the
killik species
first introduced in the dark nest
trilogy of books by troy denning
a killik that may or may not be dr
mandible also appeared in episode 5 of
season 1 of the mandalorian
sitting at the cantina bar it's also
worth noting that filmmaker peyton reed
best known for the ant-man movies
directed the passenger
thus the inclusion of this ant inspired
character
seems a not so subtle nod to the
director's marvel cinematic universe
contributions
when mando first gets back to mos eisley
after a long
strenuous walk across the desert his
first stop is at the cantina where he
finds motto in the middle of a
high-stakes card game against
dr mandible the scene doesn't last long
and their game
isn't the focus by any means but the
cards in mato's hands point to one of
the star wars universe's favorite
pastimes
a good old fashioned game of sabac
sabacc is a staple of star wars
appearing in everything from books tv
shows video games
and obviously a few of the movies it's
mentioned now and again throughout the
skywalker saga
even popping up in the background of the
force awakens
but its most notable appearance came in
2018's
solo a star wars story in the film a
young lando calrissian
cheats a young han solo out of a game
but the smuggler later gets his future
ally back by using his techniques
against him to steal a win
walking away with a millennium falcon
turning back to the mandalorian here's a
neat detail
motto's unbeatable winning hand in the
passenger
is known as an idiot's array
and it's the same winning hand lando had
in a star wars rebels episode of the
same name
not so fast it appears i have an idiot's
array
just before departing for trask mando
and the child wait
inside peli mato's hangar for their
passenger to arrive
as a token of their appreciation they
leave her with a portion of the crate
dragon meat they secured in the previous
episode
which she cooks up rather peculiarly a
treadwell droid holds up the cut of meat
to the flames of a stationary podracer
engine to roast it
a reference to a real-life star wars
eatery located at disney's
galaxy's edge theme park the restaurant
in question
is ronto roasters a neat little place
with a menu
including something for everyone while
ronto roasters
doesn't have any crate dragon steaks for
sale one of its more decorative
elements draws a neat parallel to this
mandalorian scene
at the heart of the diner you can watch
droids cook
food beneath the pod racer engine in the
same fashion as motto's droid
even though it's all for show at the
amusement park it's nice to see this
method of food preparation makes its way
into
star wars canon proper mando in the
child's journey with their passenger the
frog lady and her container of eggs
becomes a bit complicated
since they can't utilize hyperspace
travel for the sake of her unborn
children
instead they have to make the journey to
the planet trask
at sublight meaning that anyone looking
for mando will have a much easier time
finding him
that includes the new republic's x-wing
patrols who pressed the bounty hunter
relentlessly for information about his
ship and his shady dealings
we're out here sweeping for imperial
holdouts one pilot in particular
likely stood out to seasoned star wars
fans from the moment he arrived on
screen
the mastermind behind both the clone
wars and star wars rebels and an
occasional mandalorian director
dave filoni makes a brief appearance in
the passenger in a reprisal of his
season one role as trapper wolf
the character made his franchise debut
in chapter 6 the prisoner
in which he alongside fellow directors
deborah chao
and rick famous destroys ransar malk's
space hangar
following the escape of new republic
prisoner quinn
following the crash landing in the razor
crest the mandalorian the child and the
frog lady are left to survive in the
bitter cold of an unnamed ice planet
fed up with mando's sluggishness and
repairing the ship
the frog lady wanders off into the snowy
labyrinth and finds a hot spring for
herself and her eggs
concerned for their safety mando tries
to get the frog lady and her precious
cargo out of the cave
and his hunch is right in a scene akin
to something from ridley scott's alien
or john carpenter's the thing the child
unintentionally awakens a den of
spider-like creatures
known as the krikna the krikna have a
long storied history in the star wars
universe
first realized in legendary concept
artist ralph mcquarrie's the empire
strikes back sketches and initially
known
as navi white spiders while they never
appeared in that film
the krikna eventually made their spine
tingling entrance during star wars
rebels second season
in the episode the mystery of chopper
bass they later appeared in a handful of
other installments of the series
but their introduction on the
mandalorian is their first in live
action
and for those with arachnophobia
hopefully their last
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mandalorian
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one